the cdc is warning about a possible
fourth wave of coronavirus as cases rise
in parts of the country
this is vaccinations also continue to
increase about one in four adults in the
united states are now
fully vaccinated and more than 112
million people have received
at least one shot joining us now former
coronavirus task force testings are
admiral brett gerard
i thought i would maybe just ask you you
know a year from where
you think it back up to a year ago when
you were right in the middle of the
beginning of the pandemic did you ever
think
we would be at this stage where we had
this many vaccinations and shots in arms
well thanks for having me on of course
we knew that vaccines were the only way
out of the pandemic
barring everyone getting the disease so
we started working on that immediately
um but i can honestly say that nobody
would have expected
to have three authorized vaccines that
were 100
protective at the doses so we we really
do have the end in sight
it is a miraculous uh type of
accomplishment so no we could not have
imagined this type of success you
mentioned the end in sight and yet these
are the headlines
i just want to get your reaction like
how worried should we be
um the la times the washington post new
jersey.com and wink all saying that
there is a
double mutant corona coronavirus variant
that is sweeping the nation what should
we know about this
so mutations occur all the time this
particular variant
has a couple of mutations that we need
to watch
but the bottom line is is that all these
variants whether it's south african
brazil
uk or likely this new double variant
will all be protected against by the
vaccines
the vaccines work you've got to have
both of them if you have pfizer or
moderna but they give you such
protection and such diversity
that yes we need to be concerned about
these mutants we need to follow them
but this is not you know double mutant
sounds really awful and scary
the american people should not be scared
they should get their vaccines
and the end of this will become soon
after the vaccines are more widespread
about 80 percent of teachers have gotten
the first shot of vaccines you've been
on here before talking about what can
happen
and what people can do once they get a
vaccine so
in your opinion can kids and teachers
get back into the classroom
well teachers and children should be
back in the classroom
already and even dr wolinski said it's
not necessary for teachers to get the
vaccine
in texas where i am children have been
back in school since last
august my younger daughters in education
it's going very well
this is creating irreparable harm and
look at the places where children are
still not in school
washington california oregon washington
dc maryland
this is really causing irreparable harm
to children yes vaccines is an added
bonus for the teachers i am so happy
they're getting it but teachers should
should be back in school with their
students today they should have been six
months ago
i want you to listen to some sound from
the cdc director
uh walensky just take a listen to this
real quick
i'm going to reflect on the recurring
feeling i have of impending doom
so right now i'm scared our data from
the cdc today
suggests um you know that that
vaccinated people do not
carry the virus don't get sick and that
it's not just in the clinical trials but
it's also in real world data
i would advocate against general travel
overall
our guidance is silent on recommending
or not recommending fully vaccinated
people travel
so last question to you sir like how are
americans supposed to take the
information what they're seeing in their
own communities
getting the vaccine but then hearing
messages like that from the cdc
it feels like it's confusing well
there are a lot of mixed messages here
and let me just tell you
the facts where they are if you are
vaccinated and fully vaccinated
you are 95 percent protected
against getting any infection it's very
unlikely you will transmit it but there
is a small chance
i feel very comfortable traveling i'm
ready to go on cruises again with a
fully vaccinated uh crew
and and passengers um so
we're not out of this yet i don't think
we're going to have a fourth wave
because of the vaccines and the
pre-existing immunity from people
getting infected
so i still wear a mask in public because
there's still a small chance that even
vaccinated you could have a little virus
and pass it to someone
who is vulnerable but we are on our way
out of this
i do believe herd immunity is around the
corner and deaths continue to decrease
because we've done so well with our
elderly and vulnerable the end is in
sight
don't be scared be vigilant get your
vaccine
and we will be out of this all right
admiral brett gerard always pleasure to
see you thank you for the insight like
to hear that huh